le chômage problème numéro un pour 60 %
des français c'est ce qu'indique un
sondage public est ça le nouveau journal
réalisé les 19 et 20 mars auprès de 1000
personnes
l'emploi est aussi le thème principal de
la campagne présidentielle
georges marchais a présenté neuf
propositions d'actions cet après midi au
cours d'une conférence de presse
je me fixe un objectif central créé en
deux ans un million cinq cent mille
emplois nouveaux
ce qui permettra de réduire de 1 million
le nombre à le nombre actuel des
chômeurs je souligne que 900 mille de
ces emplois
c'est à dire la partie la plus
importante seront des emplois tant la
production ce que je considère comme
indispensable pour sortir de la crise